i don't know i think you know the show
is so beloved and i think could survive
in a variety of different ways but
ultimately like like any like all good
things all good things come to an end so
i don't know if this is the last season
or if it'll be a couple more seasons or
the show will reinvent itself
i really don't know i know the fans
don't want it to end
no it's their fault
and we got you and i'm never gonna hurt
you ever again
okay how has it been on set i mean it
must be so wonderful to see each other
i've been with these people for almost
seven years now you know i've spent more
time with them with my family sometimes
so
to kind of come back to work after seven
months and not be able to hug and
squeeze them is
throughout the seven years that i've
been there now we've always played you
know
make-believe circumstances you know what
i mean so call cut
and then this illusion that we've
created that wasn't real goes away we
all go back to our lives
this is not like that you know we call
cut and we are in
the situation that we're actually
shooting who died
everyone marvin lindstrom
doris sanchez tom richardson you treated
him
yeah the retired choir director he
loved fishing i'm excited to share the
stories that we're telling
so we really want to you know pay
tribute to our healthcare workers and
all the families that have been affected
hopefully honor them
and giacomo is also helping canadian
families by partnering with outerwear
brand novus
for their no cold shoulder initiative i
think these
times have been so difficult on people
and families
so um no cold shoulder is an initiative
where we're asking people to donate
their gently used
jackets so that we can help other people
who need to get those jackets we're just
urging everybody to go to
notecoldshoulder.com and find out how
you can get involved
and get your jacket donated and with
every purchase
we're giving all of our customers this
beanie
right here or two as we say in canada
don't worry a thank you from novus for
for helping those in need